las vegas kicking off the fourth of july
weekend with a downtown show
the plaza is celebrating 50 years
tonight with a spectacular round of
fireworks
it is the first of many we can expect to
see this weekend
sasha loftis had the best view of
anybody tonight joins us across the
street
from circa big smile hey sasha
hey there brian we did have a great view
as the plaza kicked off
that fantastic fireworks show to mark 50
years
half a century here in downtown las
vegas and we were here
at circa with as you said the best view
of really anyone tonight
now the show started at 10 o'clock this
is actually the first of three nights
we'll see celebrations
like this downtown the plaza hotel and
casino first opened its doors on july 2
1971
and it has remained a city staple ever
since
now those over at plaza and here at
circa chose to welcome guests in
honor of that special anniversary and
the holiday weekend
we spoke to so many who see tonight as a
comeback for vegas
fourth of july is like the big opening
for vegas
covid is kind of over and done with
we'll see about that but
uh yeah it should be a big party good
time it's nice we're excited to come for
the fourth of july
[Music]
now this is just one of many fireworks
celebrations you'll see all across the
valley through
sunday the 4th of july the plaza is
holding two more celebrations tomorrow
night
and sunday night of course you'll see
fireworks celebrations all across
downtown
and all down the strip as well we have a
list of all those firework locations and
independence day celebrations for you
that's on our website 8newsnow.com for
now reporting live at circa sasha loftis
8 news now